you know we have today the highest level
of unemployment of a record and the
highest level of youth unemployment have
a regular three times higher than adults
in many countries and in some regions
fifty percent of all unemployed and we
are facing a jobless recovery in a
number of countries so the key question
is push job creation at the center of
the recovery how could I put in
politically we need to put the same
policy decisiveness the same creativity
the same capacity for out-of-the-box
thinking that went into saving banks
into saving jobs into creating jobs into
the investment process that's necessary
and also for youth employee how do we do
it we can't repeat the mistakes of the
past we're not going to get out of the
crisis by repeating the policies that
led us into the processes so
International Labor Organization has put
proposal which is a global jobs back to
be able to address in a primary and a
fundamental way nations of jobs and
particularly phone